on this episode we talk about Twitter
140-character limit me establishing
myself as the boss and you jumping away
from that hundred thousand dollar-plus
job to go into your
[Music]
yes
ask Gary B
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is someone 47 of the askgaryvee
show kept the door open today cup
Caitlyn on the door to be open brings a
little extra energy I didn't like that
15 got so much DAP so I want to give 16
some love Brandon Barnes got a new
haircut from Rosie I'm loving it you
should come over and show us up Caitlyn
with my favorite employees sit in the
background cool I'm a good mood heading
to London tomorrow and yesterday shows
awesome 15 brought some serious energy
good to be back in the main saddle as I
like to call it against the pain saddle
main saddle India let's get into don't
don't be self-conscious help you watch
147 episodes of self lifting self-esteem
building come on here we go knowing you
before that get over your Kyle know
something I wanted to show nation just
wanted NATO nation to see your hat I
have Pokemon oh that's you sorry Kyle
Kyle asks with most of your employees
knowing you before they worked for you
how did you establish your authority as
the boss Kalin please let's find out
question is you know when most of my
police knew who I was prior to working
it's my authority did you know what was
prior to I knew you were in the
marketing everybody see that that's a
Scoob you'd be stunned I I appreciate
everybody thinking everybody knows me I
would say more than happy not seventy
sixty-three percent of the employees did
not know who I was so it was India step
on there you go right like you know you
know Eddie come here you know so I'm
gonna keep rolling here one whether they
knew or they didn't
there was just no breathing room I was
gonna I'm the CEO of the company I'm
gonna stablished hey did you know who I
was before you started working here I
did oh crap I didn't know how my friend
was reading Thank You economy got it I
just talked to Gary and that's when I
find out about Vayner thank God for that
book uh so you know most of them didn't
the ones that did it wasn't hard they
either had one of two things they had no
idea who I was easy to establish
Authority I'm a damn CEO they knew who I
was they knew what my accolades respect
for the game I'm a damn CEO easy easy
peace Nikhil asks what do you think of
Twitter's plan to remove the 140
character limit make you I think this is
a tremendous execution by twitter
twitter really needs a jumpstart in a
lot of ways and really the reason that
had a limit was because of the
technology in place because it was
really in the old 160 character limit or
something of that nature with the phone
structure of Texan like like there's no
reason at this point to keep that limit
they created creativity I think it
served the purpose but you've gotta
evolve or die and I think the freedom of
more characters could be helpful plus
you have a lot of base of people over
the last eight years that use it that
will still keep things short and tight
for me I can see us now doing incomplete
blog post type things like we do on
Facebook in a Twitter environment could
open up some opportunity I think this is
a very smart move
she did move a move that I'm excited to
test out I think this was really neat
Garrett asks what's the worst mistake a
potential vaynermedia employee can make
during an interview with you nothing
because mainly I'm on feel I'm actually
not even paying attention to what
everybody's saying I'm actually more
trying to get the vibe of it so you know
obviously then that would be lying or
trying to fake the funk I don't mind
what people come in and pander to my ego
I like it I don't mind when they don't
know who the hell I am I like it
see that's what's fun when you want to
rise like a phoenix it's cool and when
you think I leave yourself it's cool
I get to win no matter what it's a great
structured game so I'm not really
analyzing for I'm not there's nothing
anybody can do literally nothing you
told me that there you know this company
stings I'm just here for whatever I kind
of we really get like I get into like
teenage girl guy they were so like ooh
I'm gonna turn this guy around right so
we go through that route or you're
convinced it is the greatest thing of
all time again that's somebody that's
all bought in I think I'm so goddamn
optimistic that uh that it really
doesn't matter what you do I'm probably
gonna want to hire you regardless if you
don't get hired by me it means that
there just wasn't a practical puzzle
piece need or some it wasn't something
you did and then Mike asks do you or
have you hired college dropouts at
vaynermedia yes we've got it this is not
something that even registers in my mind
a fact you guys know how I feel about
school
pretty pretty hardcore I got hit up on
Twitter a bunch of times that says
vaynermedia has you know this need for
two years ago I don't know college like
whatever whatever our requirements are
and I didn't even know like I assume
that we did that as a standard thing
that HR at one point did it AJ or
Kelly when she was a managing director
or somebody in HR and literally I
reached out and like we've changed it I
think we've added like or have ox5 like
I didn't even know Stefan was or wasn't
it doesn't he doesn't even register for
me if you've got the skills you've got
the skills I know once you get it in
here whether you go to Harvard where
you're from
smart word it doesn't matter the game
starts and then that's what ends up
mattering college/university
week anniversary schmarvard we can go
marvered you like this is you know
you're gonna create a few figures around
all right cool please leave in the
comments who's in for a smarter to you
but t-shirt but this is where I'm weird
and gangster do not say it because you
think I'm gonna be pumped and then not
do it I will literally track the data if
you put a comment saying you're getting
one to see if you then got one Gabe
you're not on the show
alright looking for statements I
appreciate that also I'm looking for
more share monsters one of the things
that I've noticed is I've taken the foot
off the pedal on the right hooks I want
to show to grow I want more people to
watch it it is my oxygen will people
watch it works I am more likely we can
hit a plateau more likely we can
actually get to you know our our end
goal of getting 200 episodes in of this
show which
yes
are we back yeah yeah so happy cool
that's it you keep asking questions I'll
keep answering them
in that part there's like a lot of signs
like Dirac made us take a rock made a
mistake here I made a mistake in that
transition part
[Music]